foreign
[Music]
attractive
that would be very intimidating targeted
more likely
I
feel like what he said about the women
being
and you guys can let me know
like I don't think men really care how
smart you are I think he's just saying
nothing to them you know if they don't
want like a box of rocks but I don't
think it's like I don't think to me I
just from what I know it doesn't seem
like men are intimidated by a girl being
smart
enough
foreign
and like that's like when they say oh
they're intimidated by it it seems like
it's not them actually being smart it's
just better than everyone else well it
depends
because
I mean
she wasn't the sort of person who was
parading it around
it's also quite sweet
[Music]
what you're talking about I think
I was just thinking
like it doesn't seem like better
intimidated by intelligence
intelligent
small women
find it hard
to actually find something
that is also because he didn't say it's
you guys
um
I'm 51. so I'm not older
in between so so being intimidated maybe
can be
away they're not interested at all about
you and they don't want to have anything
to do with you all right so obviously
so
yeah
um
from my experience especially by Leading
approach in 3-4 country
the last five years
slowly this completely changed so if
it's warmer maybe it's not interested to
demand as a gender it just doesn't
quite goal for the job he does or
whatever else she eases which tools
I mean the last five
or three of it
still left me for a woman
in the first place right that's a low
level
yeah white section of women running
around
speaking to yeah
if I can say
thank you
basically that we're talking about the
YouTube the two guys together
oh yeah you know
and my oldest friend bisexuals
huh and opportunity the way I do sex
with you no really so in between if you
are sitting here
what do you think you do for a sex
Methodist
all talking about
[Music]
the genitalia which is
the girls looking at me
yeah um
Academy testing tested um I was just
looking around at my classmates I was
like this is so whack I was so bored out
of my skull
into their classes where you got to meet
with others
like it was one day a week
and so yeah I do think that that has
impacted my dating now I think you have
to be you know nice about it but I think
like in general and I'm not trying
though I don't want to be with a man
that's dumber than me and I don't think
that having a high IQ as a man equates
to having a PhD because some of the
smartest people I've ever met in my life
are blue collar could have been
out there that are probably
a problem but um yeah
right
but in that circumstance you just have
to be
it has led me to hurt your men I think
that's true
yeah I kind of do I'm not even gonna
front but you know resource acquisition
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible